what i'm going to be doing in this video  is going through my own reasoning for  why i'm 100 sure we'll be seeing a new  ipad air at next month's events and then  i'll explain why our ipad air 5 custom  renders have a square camera bump on  them the current ipad air 4 makes  literally no sense right now in the  current ipad lineup so in my opinion  apple needs to fix this messed up ipad  lineup asap the 2022 ipad air will be  sticking to the same lcd display that we  currently have which is a bit  disappointing the overall design will  remain unchanged with the same 10.9 inch  display and the same touch id power  button will get a four speaker audio  system it'll get an upgrade to the a15  chip along with everything else that the  ipad mini received last year but that it  would gain a dual lens camera system and  that is exactly why our new renders come  with a dual lens square bump it'll still  be carrying the same price of  599 dollars